vous n'êtes pas venu seul mais je suis
venu avec 10,6 la poste d'ici la fosse
elle a un frère mais j'ai tué ma fille
mon mieux au placard j'ai fait de la
prison et vous avez fait de la prison
non ce que je ferais chier qui a acheté
aux cuisines là il m'a mis au placard
maintenant ce projet a pu venir
du coup mais là je suis chaud là je
prépare un album ma mère ça va parler de
quoi il ya une thématique c'est un album
concept t'inquiète mythique jeudi direct
comment ça va se passer on appris des
stars j'ai fait des chansons pour des
stars j'ai mis à l'honneur destin qui
comme ça la première que j'ai fait ces
paris s'il tonne
j'ai fait un pari pas 10 c'est bon c'est
qu'on voit c'est bon c'est bon on a
compris dès de l'album alors s'il devait
préparer d'autres choses pour ce soir et
bien sûr frère on va faire jouer toute
la ta sur la tête de ma mère christophe
manas a fait entrer l'accusé tout le
journal garde la pêche ou pas
sur chaque fois de trop christophe
hondelatte solaire il a fait la
meilleure punchline dr house c'est pas
mickey mouse il a couché le rap français
et mme simone à la retraite s'arrêter
c'est fini la dernière on a ce soir on
va faire deviner des chansons de la fête
j'ai un peu remasterisés sa remix est
passé sous les platines de deux minutes
au micro-ondes thermostat despair sa
part directe l'info mettre les faut
mettre les frites parce que lui il a les
shows de faire aller prier et berlin se
sont complexes
on nous donne des cours sur le sexe elle
apprend la vie secrète des angoisses et
de la bête de ceux qui trouvent la cour
d'une montre et leur bible dit
sur des puces sur le zizi tout vous
saurez tout sur le zizi
pour lui c'est un reconnu
mais c'est vrai bon allez vas-y ya trop
de quoi sur le plateau de tout le monde
bosse
l'épidémie est fatigué je suis parti sur
les challenges projet ma carte de crédit
à la peau de l'ours deuxième place un
bambou j'ai rencontré ma nana la fille
du roi baudouin qu'est ce que tu as fait
piccioni rouamba mes classes quand je
touche des ananas
si demain sur les chevaux sur la tête
avec les bras les recoins pas
s'expliquer soit que toutes les analyses
air connu jordi
nora qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
vrai que cela me salopette vous
l'apporté mieux vous l'apporté mieux bon
la dernière c'est la vase sy sall elle
est puissante
c'est là vous allez saigner du nez les
yeux et j'ai envie de me perforer les
oreilles et qu'une personne est elle
même
monsieur
tous les anniversaires
paul populaire pour les nouveaux mariés
et la nouvelle année le chef dans les
discothèques
quand on veut faire la fête il n'y a
rien de plus simple il suffit de danser
tout son éclat à la queue leu leu
tout démarre à la queue leu leu tout le
monde chante que le hope est la plaie
que
il s'est dit
je vais l'interprète concert tu vous a
régalé c'est nous a régalés c'est bon je
pense qu'on m'a donné vraiment merci
mais bien ses débuts
si nos invités du jour nous avions
triste informat je vous rappelle